bonjour patrick phoque merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors
pour vous c'était important de rappeler
que pas sanitaire n'est pas forcément la
solution miracle
alors et ça nous rappelle surtout que le
vaccin est très efficace et que art si
c'est vrai le ce que rappelle le comité
et le conseil scientifique c'est qu'il
peut y avoir des contaminations rare
mais ça existe des chez les gens
vaccinés ce qu'on sait c'est que le
vaccin protège absolument contre les
formes graves des hospitalisations et
les décès et donc le fait de faire des
bulles sécurisé où le virus ne le dit
pas ne circule pas mais circule beaucoup
moins et moins contaminant oui c'est
logique chez logic pour inciter les gens
à la vaccination qui est très efficace
après ce que dit le conseil scientifique
c'est que se passa une terre n'est pas
un blanc-seing mais sans le sait depuis
le début d'avoir appasamy père c'est pas
s'exonérer de toutes les contraintes de
distanciation social de port du masque
on peut rester peut-être contaminants
malgré qu'on a été vaccinée ça n'a pas
encore tout à fait prouvé on sait qu'il
ya des gens qui sont porteurs du virus
qui peuvent être porteurs du virus est
très peu malade on ne sait pas quelle
est leur taux de contagiosité quoi donc
c'est vrai que le court ces
scientifiques rappellent simplement des
choses logique qu'on sait de longue date
ça ne remet pas du tout en cause
l'existence du pass sanitaire qu'il faut
absolument maintenir si on veut réduire
l'épidémie alors justement beaucoup de
manifestations en france 1 ces derniers
temps contre le pass sanitaire est ce
que vous pensez peut-être que le
gouvernement un moment donné a manqué de
pédagogie
quant à l'explication se passe sanitaire
s'est fait expliquer des phénomènes
épidémiologique et scientifique c'est
très compliqué c'est vrai que le conseil
scientifique est plus à l'aise avec ça
le gouvernement lui légifère il fait des
lois qui comme toutes les noix elle peut
paraître brutale parfois mais bon c'est
la loi il faut absolument qu'on qu'on
vienne à bout de cette épidémie et on
irait lèvera pas si on voit pas se
vacciner massivement tout simplement or
c'est vrai à ce que sap a été expliqué
jean serrat est aussi un certain nombre
de gens qui ne veulent pas entendre
d'explications qui sont bornées sur leur
attitude anti vaccin anti passe et des
gens qui ne veulent céder en rien quoi
voilà doc c'est un affrontement entre un
petit nombre ce que vous voyez à moins
de 150 mille deux cent mille personnes
il ya 45 millions de gens qui sont déjà
vaccinées donc faut pas oublier et le
rapport de force globalement les gens se
vaccinent pas ce qu'ils veulent se
protéger veulent protéger leurs amis
leurs familles les leurs ils veulent
retourner au travail le retourner au
restaurant au cinéma ils veulent vivre
c'est le vaccin ne libère c'est le co
vide qui nous prend et qui le prive de
liberté on peut pas habilités on peut
pas manifester en disant liberté et
refuser le vaccin ce n'est pas possible
c'est pour moi quelque chose de
totalement incompréhensible parce que la
liberté ne passera que par la lutte
acharnée contre ce vaccin est ce que
justement peut-être le l'émergent du
variant belle ta chance peut-être tels
que choses sont peut-être la donne
concernant l'efficacité du dupas
sanitaires on sait que le variant delta
se diffuse plus rapidement plus vite oui
alors effectivement les variants delta
nous apporte plusieurs messages d'abord
que c'est effectivement qu'il est
beaucoup plus contagieux qu'il met que
les vaccins restent globalement
globalement efficace même s'il ya des
petites baisse d'efficacité dans
certains domaines mais c'est tout ce que
nous apprend ce variant sait qu'il va
s'étendre à l'ensemble de la population
à la vitesse grand v la peau puissance
jeunes et les enfants qui pour l'instant
été peu touché semblent plus en danger
actuellement avec ces virus variant
delta qui qui peut les mettre en danger
puis on voit quand même il faut faut
l'avouer des formes graves chez des gens
qui jusqu'à présent n'en faisait pas des
gens des adultes jeunes des gens un
facteur de risque mais qui ont 30 40 ans
jusqu'à présent on a vu que les gens on
savait que le principal facteur de
risque du coït c'était l'âge donc après
65 ans est devenu un risque gravissime
et ben c'est âgées avec le brillant
delta est devenu de loin inférieure c +
65 ans est beaucoup plus bas quoi c'est
beaucoup plus bas et c'est ça qu'il faut
que les gens comprennent c'est que ce
variant delta va être sans doute
dangereux pour la population jeune là où
jusqu'à présent les autres souches
virales ne l'était pas et est-ce que
aussi ce variant delta a remis peut-être
en cause l'efficacité
du vaccin en tout cas sur la durée
alors vous savez on en apprend tous les
jours alors on apprend que l'immunité
diminue assez rapidement chez des
personnes âgées d'où l'intérêt de faire
une troisième dose chez des gens depuis
80 ans 81 ans dès le mois de septembre
les gens de plus de 65 ans on sait pas
trop mais on estime qu'il faudra
peut-être leur donner une deuxième dose
mois d'octobre en fin d'année voyez on
apprend tous les jours c'est vrai que
ces variants delta c'est peut-être pas
lié aux variants delta mais on se rend
compte que l'antico les eaux le taux
d'anticorps d'anticorps produit par le
par le vaccin peut-être non pas une
durée de vie aussi longue qu'on espérait
voilà vous parlez de troisième dose là
en tout cas pour les personnes les plus
à risque dans les prochaines semaines
s'il y a de nouveaux variants dans les
semaines dans l'émoi dans les années à
venir est-ce qu'il faudra plusieurs
rappels des nombreux rappels troisième
dos 4e 10 5e doses alors s'il devait y
avoir je suis pas pharmacologue à je
vais vous répondre comme ça de que de ma
propre initiative si demain il y avoit
il devait y avoir un variant qui devait
devenir résistant aux vaccins bien sûr
qu'il faudra modifier les vaccins comme
tous les ans modifie le vaccin la grippe
l'industrie sait faire on a su codé la
protéine spahic pour les 20 premiers
variant pour les premiers shoots
première souche ça sera très rapide à
faire on a vu il faut pas des années et
des années même si c'est devenu un
reproche on peut en quelques semaines en
quelques quelques mois fabriquer des
nouvelles souches da et rennes
à kiki caudron pour la nouvelle protéine
spykee et donc la résist problème de
résistance n'est pas saoul et ne mettra
pas en échec les futurs vaccins ça c'est
tout à fait sûr merci beaucoup patrick
fois que d'avoir et moi avec nous ce
matin sur arte france je rappelle avec
qui vous êtes médecin généraliste merci
beaucoup